- Si la Chine aide la Russie,
nous n'hésiterons pas à imposer
des sanctions économiques contre
le géant chinois. Antony Blinken
qui a dit ça aujourd'hui.
La nouvelle qui a fait réagir.
Il faut remonter quelques jours
en arrière, c'est dimanche,
quand le New York Times et
le Financial Times révèlent,
selon leurs sources, que Poutine
a demandé de l'aide à la Chine.
Jean-François Lépine, que vous
connaissez bien, bonsoir.
- Bonsoir Patrice.
- On va essayer de démêler
tout ça. Première réaction
des Chinois au tout début,
je remonte il y a trois
semaines, on est prudent.
On appuie pas, on ne dit pas
bravo mais en même temps,
on ne dénonce pas.
- Avant les Jeux olympiques,
si on se souvient bien le
président de Xi Jinping a reçu
dans une rencontre officielle
importante avant l'ouverture
des Jeux le président Poutine.
On a fait à ce moment-là
des déclarations d'amitié et de
solidarité commune et tout ça.
Après ça, on n'a pas cessé,
la Chine a été inondée
d'informations complètement
contradictoires à ce qu'on
entend ici sur ce qui se passait
vraiment. La Chine a commencé
par parler de crise, plutôt que
de guerre. Ensuite, on a parlé
d'une attaque défensive
de la part de la Russie. On n'a
jamais montré au public chinois
les tonnes de réfugiés,
les dommages causés par
les bombardements russes.
Mais tout ça est entrain
un petit peu de changer.
On pourra parler de tous
les aspects de ça. Mais vous
l'avez dit vous-même, c'est
compliqué de comprendre
la situation de la Chine. Parce
que la Chine est en train
de changer actuellement. Puis
je peux vous dire, mardi
dernier, dans le Washington
Post, l'ambassadeur chinois
à Washington a prit la peine
de publier une lettre en disant:
c'est vrai, en reconnaissant que
la position chinoise n'était pas
clair. En disant d'abord on ne
savait pas. Quand Monsieur
Poutine a rencontré Xi Jinping
on ne savait pas l'ampleur de ce
qui allait se passer. On n'a pas
non plus demandé à Poutine de
reporter son attaque après
les Jeux. Ça c'était une
accusation qu'on faisait aussi
à la Chine. Donc on n'a pas
offert d'armes à la Chine,
à la Russie, et on offrira pas
d'armes à la Russie. Démenti
de toute cette histoire-là
aussi. Dans le Washington Post,
il y a deux jours. Et puis
l'ambassadeur dit: on veut la
paix, on veut la fin de la
guerre. On emploie maintenant
le terme guerre en Chine.
- Donc évolution. Quel intérêt
la Chine aurait eu ou aurait
à aider Poutine? Que ce soit
financièrement, parce que ça lui
coûte une fortune cette guerre
Poutine, ou militairement. Quel
intérêt il y aurait?
- La Russie est un allié
important de la Chine, parce que
les deux pays se sentent un peu
victimes de démarches de la part
des pays alliés, des pays
occidentaux, y compris du Japon,
d'essayer de bloquer leur
développement. Il y a cette
espèce de paranoïa commune.
Il y a aussi des échanges
commerciaux importants entre
les deux pays. Des alliances
sur le plan militaire aussi.
Les Chinois ont depuis 2017,
80 % de leurs importations
militaires viennent de Russie.
Il y a là un lien très
important, importations aussi
de céréales, gros importateurs
de céréales russes.
Et d'énergie, hydrocarbures
en provenance de Russie aussi.
Donc des partenaires qui sont
solides. Mais là, le
comportement de Vladimir Poutine
mais les Chinois dans l'embarras
puis je peux vous expliquer
pourquoi.
- Justement est-ce que ce sont
des craintes de sanctions
économiques qui viendraient
de l'Europe, des États-Unis,
vis-à-vis la Chine qui font
réfléchir les Chinois
actuellement?
- D'abord, les Chinois
ne s'attendaient pas à
une guerre comme celle-là en
plein coeur de l'Europe.
L'Europe pour la Chine c'est
le client et le partenaire
commercial le plus important au
monde. Les Chinois ne veulent
pas de fragilité dans ça.
Ils ne veulent pas surtout d'un
conflit qui pourrait s'étendre
sur la planète et qui crée
une déstabilisation majeure.
Il ne faut pas oublier que la
Chine a une obsession; elle veut
devenir le plus rapidement
possible la plus grande
puissance mondiale. En Chine
ça va bien, et le président
Xi Jinping, qui va solliciter
l'automne prochain un troisième
mandat, ce qui n'est pas permis
vraiment en vertu de la
tradition politique récente
en Chine, il veut un troisième
mandat. C'est mal vu dans son
pays il a besoin de stabilité.
Il ne s'attendait certainement
pas à une opération comme
celle-là de la part de la
Russie, qui déstabilise non
seulement la région, l'Europe
complet mais aussi la planète.
On en parle tous les jours.
- Est-ce que Jean-François s'il
mettait tout son poids, peut-il
selon vous faire reculer
Poutine?
- Il y a différentes choses qui
se disent et qu'on peut
observer. C'est que
l'administration chinoise
a tellement monté la population
chinoise contre l'OTAN, contre
les partenaires européens,
contre les alliés et pour la
Russie, comment maintenant et
c'est le problème apparemment du
président Jinping comment peut-
il se positionner, comme
quelqu'un qui va obtenir de
Vladimir Poutine des
concessions, donc une victoire
moindre que  ce que Poutine
voudrait avoir. Et donc, comment
expliquerait-t-il, comment
Xi Jinping expliquerait-il ça
à une population chinoise qui
est montée contre l'OTAN. C'est
la faute de l'OTAN, c'est notre
faute qui se passe ce n'est pas
la faute de Poutine. C'est comme
ça que les Chinois voient
les choses actuellement. Donc
oui, il a cette difficulté là à
intervenir, mais c'est évident
que si Monsieur Xi Jinping
rejoignait le concert
des alliés, pour mettre
des pressions. Surtout aux
Nations unies, la Chine s'est
abstenue aux Nations unies,
pourtant la Chine a un principe
fondamental: il faut respecter
la souveraineté et le territoire
des états dans le monde.
La Chine a intérêt à ça parce
qu'elle veut qu'on respecte le
sien. C'est un principe
fondamental pour les Chinois.
Pourtant ils acceptent
ouvertement depuis 20 jours
ce qui se passe actuellement
en Ukraine. Qui est aussi
un partenaire commercial très
important de la Chine. Ce
deux poids, deux mesures-là,
et d'ailleurs l'ambassadeur
chinois a dit dans sa lettre
ce que les Chinois disent,
mais on n'a pas vu la couleur de
ça. Que là maintenant il y a de
l'aide humanitaire qui s'en va
vers les Ukrainiens. Entre
autres des couvertures. Ça ne
changera pas beaucoup
les choses. Mais s'il veut
intervenir, c'est sûr que la
Chine un tel poids auprès de
Moscou, que Moscou serait assez
nations qui essaient de forcer
la Russie à faire des compromis
et surtout à faire un cessez-le-
feu.
- Dernière question
Jean-François avant de vous
laisser aller. Taiwan, dès
le jour un, les gens ont dit:
si les Chinois reconnaissaient
les préoccupations de Poutine,
pour avoir, pour être maître
chez lui est-ce à dire que
Taiwan ça serait, il y aurait
une carte routière pour envahir
Taiwan pour les Chinois. Est-ce
qu'on peut faire un rapport ou
- Alors on peut faire un rapport
certainement. Parce que les
Chinois et  redisent que Taiwan
va revenir dans le giron de la
Chine. La seule différence que
Taiwan n'est pas considéré par
la Chine comme pays indépendant.
C'est considéré comme une
province qui a quitté la Chine.
Et que la Chine veut revoir dans
son giron. Ce qui a changé,
parce qu'effectivement,
je disais moi-même au début
de l'offensive russe que les
Chinois observent étroitement
ce qui se passe. Parce que les
autres se disent, si un jour
il y a tnú H8clarahh<ç
d'indépendance à Taiwan et qu'on
veut forcer la note et qu'on
veut envahir Taiwan, comment le
monde va-t-il réagir? Ce qu'on
dit maintenant, même en Chine,
c'est que la force de la
réaction des alliés de
l'Ukraine, la force des
sanctions économiques et elle
que les Chinois se disent: oh!
Que se passerait-il si on posait
ce geste-là? Ce n'est pas
tellement une menace militaire
encore que il faut voir la
résistance des ukrainiens, les
militaires qu'on apporte aux
ukrainiens qu'est-ce que ça va
donner? Mais les Chinois
observent vraiment cette
situation la et de toute
évidence il y a de plus en plus
de gens au niveau du leadership
chinois qui ont une certaine
influence auprès de Xi Jinping
qui lui dise: peut-être que tu
aurais intérêt à calmer le jeu,
avant que les alliés firent
d'autres leçons de ce conflit la
qui pourrait éventuellement
s'appliquer à nous. C'est
vraiment pour ça que la Chine a
une attitude qui est vraiment en
train de changer actuellement.
- Jean-François Lépine, très
intéressant, toujours un plaisir
de vous parler. Merci beaucoup.
- C'est moi qui vous remerci